foreign
[Laughter]
[Music]
for him
anymore
[Music]
foreign
[Laughter]
um
[Music]
if anything
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Laughter]
[Music]
from me
and welcome back to the riddles podcast
in the Dunya the three Muslims
alhamdulillah we're finally back with
the home base all three of us are here
and it feels good how you guys doing
today
[Music]
how are you
alhamdulillah
you're not stressed out anymore
questions going
home
to marry things good
um I mean says finally the three Muslims
wasn't expecting all three of you
finally without the cap fight
Muslims for once
a lot to everyone who said welcome guys
we're glad to be back and we're talking
about some pretty important stuff today
so I think inshallah we should just jump
right into it what do you guys say
honestly man I can't believe people in
the comments really thought we got
prolonged
they thought that maybe I should take
time to explain whenever you see
somebody
who whose head is is either big or the
same size as one of ours they're on the
show if their head is off to the side
and they're smaller in the corner or
something like the way Andrew and Pearls
is in this thumbnail they're not on the
show but we're talking about them so
that's how we're going to organize your
thumbnails inshallah so you know
we would like to have her on I reached
out to a few people who are in contact
with her to try and get her on
unfortunately
um I don't know if the message got
through to her or if she didn't want to
um but shallow we'd be 100 down to
discuss with her as we are with
basically most her most people or anyone
um but she has to be willing to you know
she has to be down to it by the looks of
the situation so far I don't think she
really is interested in talking to
Muslims but inshallah we'll discuss that
in a bit so just to give you a briefing
on the situation she took to Twitter of
all places for some reason to ask a
fundamentally difficult question for a
lot of people to you know really
um even fathom nowadays which is did the
process song really marry Aisha at the
age of of nine or Mary through the
contract at six but constantly at nine
now the issue that most Muslims took
with it including Mohamed and others
well rightfully so by the way it's a
terminology that she used she asked did
he screw a nine-year-old did he date a
nine-year-old
in what world does she not know that
Muslims don't date in what world does
she not know that come on
in what world does she not know
that she shouldn't use this kind of
language when talking about Muslims like
maybe you know your women where you're
from screw maybe they get screwed
because we protect our women or at least
that's the goal of Islam alhamdulillah
so
alhamdulillah regardless
she later
only really vocalized the voice of some
Anonymous historian who she says she
basically put out tweets on her on this
person's behalf saying
that she did not have puberty and this
is wrong and these people are biased
these people are wrong at the same time
the fact that he's stating line
everything out that it was completely
okay
what do I mean I mean that the person in
the argument stated that the age of
majority was around puberty
okay I should have puberty therefore is
okay she was the agent majority for the
time their problem was they didn't
believe Aisha Happy for some reason for
some reason they had no evidence for
this didn't share anything they just
called everyone else bogus for saying so
even though every scholar even early
Scholars at the time of the uh the
Italian tablets having believed that she
in the sahaba as well believe that she
uh started menstruating and hit a period
uh or puberty pardon me at nine years
old so this has never been important
contention in this whole discussion the
issue has never been whether she had
Purity or not this is just something
that I've seen recently because I think
people know they can't really
um discuss it morally from whatever
standpoint they have whether they're an
atheist or a Christian or even a Hindu
because they have that stuff in their
books as well so after all of that
took place and she only vocalized
racially anti-islam rhetoric she only
seemed to want to believe the anti-islam
rhetoric the the belief that she was 19
instead of nine and she made a 10-year
mistake somehow even though she narrated
thousands of Hadith somehow she made a
10-year mistake or one of the the Hadith
transmitters accidentally said 19
instead of nine because in Arabic he
would say like one nine instead of 19.
you know so like they just added a one
or something like that it's like how do
you make or they sorry they forgot the
one instead of saying it how do you make
a mistake like that if they made
mistakes like that they wouldn't be top
level narrators the Hadith wouldn't be
as widely transmitted as it was so the
Loops have to jump to to say that but
she that seemed to be the case she
wanted to believe even going as far as
to say I can understand 11 or 12 but
nine is like so what makes what makes 11
okay and not two years earlier
if the person is as developed as some 11
year olds like there is no
um uh you know
um qualifying it there's no way to
qualify it based on an age there's no
standard for it there based on age
but what do you guys think so far from
from the situation I described
it's nothing new bro this has been a
criticism for many years
and it's it's not right it does cause a
lot of Fitness bro in the community
cause a lot of doubts in a lot of people
that are misinformed or they fall into
the fallacy of presentism they look at
things from a modern lens with Western
laws but this is why you have people
like the Brother full metal theist that
has made academic criticisms and
refutations on these claims yeah yeah
and I think actually behind ajab has a
really really good two-part course uh or
a video I guess Series where he was
teaching a class on this topic on the
sapiens Institute and it's on YouTube it
is so
amazing I'd say academically the way it
breaks it down from the different angles
from the Islamic angle from how a
Christian might attack and how to
respond to atheist might attack how to
respond all the way to what's maybe in
the Hindu scriptures he mentions towards
the end and what some of the academics
say about the age of majority and the
age of maturity about when people were
conce considered mature about how you
know childhood is has now become a
social construct and he made a very
interesting point which I I just can't
like I wanted to save this for if we
ever speak to Pearl but I just I I can't
hold back to be honest I think it's such
an amazing point that he made which is
when you ask people like Pearl what is a
woman
or these Trad cons or Matt Walsh what is
a woman what do you think they would say
an adult human female an adult human
female okay is that the scientific
answer or the social LG TV answer
I'm gonna be honest bro I'm pretty sure
it's scientific exactly so when they're
talking about who what is a man what is
a woman it's purely scientific
when he asks him what is a child what
would they say
would they appeal to science and say
someone who has not hit puberty
not as a child and anyone who's hit
puberty is no longer a child and I was
an adult would they use that kind of
definition just just like the people
traditionally use that definition a few
hundred years ago all throughout history
the age of majority was was basically
that would they use that no so why are
they picking and choosing why now is
childhood a social construct but a woman
isn't why can't and that's something we
discussed recently on the channel
if gender is a social construct people
can say whatever they want about it if
it's related to sex they can't same
thing with childhood so why do you pick
one scientific answer for one and then a
social construct answer for the other
you are now a Progressive Progressive
leftist if anything and you're not
traditional
I think that was an amazing point that
again not my point but Muhammad a job
made I think it was fantastic no
I know I'm talking a lot but it's a very
interesting topic on top of that
guess who she decided to visit on on
their stream
under the one
yeah red Von and David award out of
everyone if if you're sick you have a
stomachache you go to the doctor if your
toothache you go to the dentist if you
if if you have a question about physics
you go to a physicist
if you need some pills you go to the
pharmacy or you go to the doctor and
they give you the pharmacy the
Pharmaceuticals
but if you have a question about Islam
you go to an ex-muslim and uh in in a
Christian now I do this because I don't
know why an ex-muslim needs to basically
have their whole Channel dedicated to
talking about Islam and I don't know why
a Christian needs to dedicate their
whole Channel which is supposed to be
apologetics by the way to debunking
Islam 90 of this stuff is anti-islamp if
not all of it
so she goes to talk to these people
about Islam rather than just speaking to
Muslims we've invited her I'm sure
Muhammad even though you know he was
upset with what she said would be done
to talk to her we're open to it we've
extended an invitation many times I
literally responded 50 different times
to her tweets with tweets of my own
she's been invited but she goes to them
to talk about Islam
if that that speaks volumes to me I know
I want to hear your guys's thoughts but
that speaks volumes to me what do you
guys think about that
I think that is just her
kind of like you know how people they go
fatwa shopping
and they try to find the answer that
suits them
yeah
she's just looking for the thing that
suits
her way of thinking at this moment in
time
yeah yeah I agree try try and stay like
in the middle sliver it's kind of hard
when you uh he's getting caught up off
camera like that yeah but absolutely and
I was actually when I asked the question
I thought about my friend for myself for
a second and I I agree I think that
she's actually scared to get the opinion
that
um she was nine
because you just can't you know conceive
of a world that's possible but if she
herself lived just a few hundred years
ago
that would have been her reality
I in one of my tweets I responded with
the picture
um it was kind of the best estimate or
the best understanding of historically
what the age of majority was in
different states in America just like
you know in the 1800s and in the 1800s I
think majority of States had 10 as like
the age of maturity
on average some 12. so okay literally
like 200 years ago literally 200 years
ago 10 years old about 1400 years ago
nine years old that's crossing the line
so
I don't know I don't know why that is
unfathomable for her but I think she
just needs to be educated on it to be
honest
um it's just a matter if she's willing
to be so what do you think that what do
you think they discussed on the channel
or on the video what do you think could
have won David wood presented to her as
the answer
do you think they mentioned oh it's a
fallacy of presentism it's okay
um because that was how they did things
at the time and she was mature for the
time and
no probably just emotional bro of course
not on top of that they added things
that were that had nothing to do with
the situation
um or or potentially had nothing to do
with the situation so I want to talk
about it we talked about it on the live
stream where we actually reacted to
Revan David wood and um a Christian
named um John I believe what his name is
what do you mean on YouTube we discussed
this stuff there like I mentioned
Mohammed a job as a two-part series you
guys can watch that inshallah I want to
talk about what happened afterwards they
mentioned the Hadith where is playing
with with dolls she was playing with
dolls and she was with like other like
female like girls or whatever
um and they were all playing in the
process time would you know enter The
Room walk in the room and the other
girls would run away and hide and then
the person would call them out and like
to go back and play
for some reason they read this and say
therefore
when when the process I'm consummated
with her she did not have puberty
because she's playing with the doll
where how on Earth do you get to that
she's playing with the doll and it's so
funny because
um
David wood himself if you watch this
video sometimes you'll have like an
action figure behind him on the Shelf
there's something I think Ali down
mentioned in the video he'll have an
action figure behind them on the Shelf
people will be playing video games
and watching cartoons like anime and
stuff until they're 30 years old 40 50
years old they're old men playing video
games
and 1400 years ago when the only like
toy they had or the only entertainment
they had was like poetry and and dolls
and that stuff all of a sudden that
means that she's a child there have been
experts in Muhammad a job mentioned in
the video that have discussed that toys
would basically grow up with you over
time and they'd become a cherished
object for you to pass on pass on to
your later generations
so when you find a toy it doesn't
necessarily mean it actually belong to a
child
it could be someone who brought it from
childhood up to adulthood and was going
to pass it on to somebody else
so
why did they stipulate that this means
that she did not have puberty Allah it's
just a narrative that I think they want
to push even though I though many times
I think they have been educated on this
and they've they've been taught about
this before
and then later sorry go on I don't know
what's so crazy about it
I mean just the day I was a Manchester
we were in uh
this place called I think Sky Zone
something like this
D5 I don't know it's a trampoline Port
yeah yeah and some little kid shouted
out that he wanted sex
and I looked at this little kid
I just gave him this look and I looked
at my niece I was like no you're not
going to be around this little kid yeah
it's a little kid was part of me like
eight years old nine years old when I
told my sister this
my sister said yeah some kids are in
fourth grade
already having sex
so
I mean these kids in fourth grade
they're like nine ten years old
so should we
you know should we create this huge deal
I mean yes it's kind of crazy because
we're not used to it just because we're
not used to something
doesn't necessarily mean that
it's not natural I mean it sounds really
bad the way I'm saying it but it's it's
understandable that when humans when we
reach puberty
sexual thoughts begin to go through our
head yeah
you know this this is a fact I mean
there's little boys who are like five
years old six years old and they have
they have things like this going on
there they have no idea what it is
yeah they're over here touching
themselves uh I don't know what little
toys little Barbie dolls and they have
no idea what they're doing
so it's there it's it's human nature
yeah and see this is the thing like if
let's say two 12 year olds wanted to
have sex or whatever and they use
protection whatever how many people
would actually have a problem with that
and say no you cannot and how many
people actually have uh would take an
issue with that
so it's it's about this is the thing and
this is something Islam is 100 with it's
about protecting
um people who are not ready
it's about protecting people who are not
ready for for sex and for for marriage
whether they're too young or too old
so and you can this is the thing they're
they're again a lot of things are saying
go back to the video with Muhammad a job
so if you want to go go ahead and show
up but there's a place for doctors in
Islam as well
if you don't know us those who knows he
said in Hadith that basically if there's
a doctor or a practitioner or a medical
expert who basically you know prescribe
something to a person and ends up
damaging them more then the doctor
actually Bears the um the the sin of
that or the fault of that so they have a
place so you can you can consult medical
experts
on if someone is is capable or Ready or
Not Ready or whatever for a marriage and
first acts and all that stuff
so if it's about protecting people the
reason it's wrong is because it's
harmful so now I I pose a challenge to
everyone who thinks that the process of
1400 years ago when he married Aisha it
was wrong based on this principle that
it's harmful show me one Hadith where
she was harmed by it
show us a Hadith where she was harmed by
the fact that she married and
consummated married at 6009
show where it harmed her and if it
didn't harm her then you can't say it's
wrong by your own standards
I don't think that the problem is that
she was nine years old I think the
problem is with these people
is when they look at the age of the
Prophet Muhammad sallam and they see
this huge disparity
but if you look at today's day you have
guys that are like 70 something 80
something years old and they were with
women who are like 15.
what's the difference here
hmm
this is the thing like people cannot
fathom reality other than their own
people like think about you can't even
really fathom what it's like to not live
under uh liberalism to not live under
capitalism you can't really fathom what
it's like to live under any ideology
other than this any you know like
non-democratic place if you've only been
in a democratic country for in a liberal
country so you think you're going to be
able to understand you know a few
hundred years ago and like literal like
what you consider children were
basically grown adults like people at
you know 12 13 14 15
um just a few hundred years ago would do
things like you know fight in Wars
or have full families be out working in
the markets even today by the way if you
go to certain countries you see young
what we consider young boys who have
families who have kids who have families
who are maybe like they're 13 14
themselves they're out in the streets
and in the marketplace is working doing
whatever they can to make money they
have their own jobs they have their own
families getting water from walls and
all that stuff
in today's world
just not in the west that you live in
we have um a super chat here Salon
Brothers keep up the good work I was
wondering how come actually had dolls
when it's prohibited to have objects
which imitate Allah's creation so
there's two opinions one is that this
event took place before uh she hit
puberty that's one understanding of it
another one
is that the doll didn't have any facial
features so there's Halal it's only
Haram when it has facial features
foreign
and some Scholars um I I don't know I
don't remember which one exactly but
there are different commentaries on the
Hadith some Scholars said this actually
happened I think it was like 12 years
after the uh
either married or consummated so you
know when she was like 15 or 16 years
old so how do you is about when she was
15 16. so again it doesn't even fall
into the context of trying to push it in
by that understanding
bro it's human nature that we look for
things that are from our our values and
beliefs you know what I mean
you remember when you said that uh
actually you know what I was watching
this video about someone like him today
on mortgage is it permissible and he was
saying that these are people that have
generally made up their minds that they
want to get a house that they can't
afford so what they do is they don't
really care what Scholars said that is
permissible it's just the fact that one
scholar said it's permissible you know
what I mean and they're just photo
shopping yeah so I think it's
subhanallah it's it's not surprisable
even with the characters they they find
things that reinforce the beliefs just
to feel almost backed up in things that
might be deviant or wrong or immoral but
this does beg the question that I want
to ask both of you
have you guys heard about the Stockholm
syndrome argument foreign
let's even add like emotionally or
whatever by a person and you end up
falling in love with them afterwards
this is this is clearly a process in
which you don't want to be with this
person but you're either abducted or
forced by your family or kidnapped by a
person and you don't want it but
eventually you fall in love with the
person uh you're you're captive
show the evidence that she was against
it she didn't want it in any capacity in
any way
even something later on where she's like
first I didn't want to marry the prophet
but you know later I I fell in love with
them something like that show it if not
you can't make the argument an argument
is not a claim a claim is a claim I can
claim that you know you're ugly you know
that's a claim an argument is a claim
with evidence so okay that's fine you
want to claim that cool it doesn't
matter if you want to argue that please
bring your evidence and then inshallah
we can actually entertain it as if it's
um
you know something worth talking about
I think you answered it beautifully bro
we have a question here so um so when
did she hit puberty when she was 9 or 15
when she uh was nine approximately when
she was eight or nine fifteen would be
very very late and if anything that
would be you know fairly abnormal
also then the prophet saws wouldn't have
consummated the merge if it was 15
because never did he do anything that
was immoral or against the teachings of
Islam against the Commandments of Allah
yeah
you know the problem is as were these
people that they latch onto these things
that make them angry make them emotional
and make them think ah look because of
this Islam can't be the truth
I think these are people that are not
actually looking for the truth
because if you were looking for the
truth you would first take a step back
and then you would see that you've been
programmed since you were a little kid
and the way you think
the way you perceive everything has been
programmed into you and in order for you
to see things exactly for what they are
the reality step outside of The Matrix
you have the first one to actually look
for the truth
because once you want to look for the
truth then you realize oh
there's a lot of lies out there and I
need to take a step back and the moment
you take a step back you see the reality
you say oh well I've been programming
since I was a little kid what have I
been programmed with what have they been
trying to show me what is what kind of
thought patterns and behavioral patterns
were they trying to put within me ever
since I was a little kid
and once you start to deconstruct this
you start to see
the reality of why they were doing this
and then you start to see okay what are
they trying to go against you know
and one one thing this one doesn't it
brings you to Islam inevitably so if
these people over here getting upset
about this stuff
I mean genuinely if you really are
seeking the truth
you wouldn't be
angry about this you wouldn't be over
here trying to find one little thing to
justify your emotion
like if I'm angry about something
I could play the victim card I could
just continue to be angry
or
like cello and I actually
you know see why it is that I'm getting
angry
do you think this was the case bro in
your reversion to Islam
because it came from
stepping away from everything
doing the dopamine detox
I was literally away from everything
and I started to
just break every little thing down in my
head
so I'm I'm just saying man
I think genuinely with these people
they are not really looking for the
truth because even as Muslims
Allah says seek the answers read for
yourself
you ask any Muslim you as any scholar
and they will all tell you the same
thing look for the answers yourself do
not believe blindly
I mean you have Muslims that still look
to even see oh is Islam actually the
truth and through their
search they find that Islam is the truth
again it's it's genuine that that
genuine want to actually find the truth
and I don't think these people have it
at the end of the day it's um sincerity
is it's a huge huge part of it you know
like you're saying you have to want the
truth you have to really look for it
we're presenting people with what we
believe to be the truth
um with as best argument that we can
bring
and may Allah guide us and you guys
inshallah if you see the value in it
then really consider Islam genuinely
don't just make it one of those things
like oh yeah maybe and then forget about
it
you know really look into Islam
genuinely and if you think that the
argument is wrong
counter it no problem
you know bring your best counter
argument or why you think the argument's
wrong
inshallah we could discuss
I mean just bro just think about this
for a second
you have a kid in school kids nowadays
they are being taught from this book
about Pride
now I'm not even gonna say which one it
is because I feel like everyone here
already understands which one I'm
talking about these kids are being
taught this
now as these kids begin to grow up
do you think
that they will be for or against
if they're being taught this in school
and their parents are okay with it their
friends are okay with it the class is
okay with it everyone around them is
okay with it
please answer me the question do you
think that they will be all right with
it or do you think they're gonna be
against it they're going to be okay with
it it's going to shape their reality
they wouldn't really know anything other
than that
bro
if that doesn't scare you
into actually looking at your own belief
system
and how you perceive things
I mean I don't know
yeah
that's a great point and just finally
you know I have so much respect for
people who come to Islam after living in
in today's age in today's world in the
western societies because you have one
very specific way of life and then you
have Islam that counteracts that that
way in so many different points on so
many different levels and people see
that and people go with it and people
are okay with it because they realize
Islam is the truth and they want to
submit to Allah they want to believe in
God they want to practice the religion
that God sent for Humanity even if it
means giving up on the things that you
know they were doing even just a month
or two months or a year ago so may Allah
do you want to get into that because
many people would rather say that Islam
seems like a very specific way of life
and outside of that you can live however
you want to
I don't necessarily think that's wrong
but it defines it like defined specific
like what makes something specific
versus not specific so I don't know why
my camera doesn't want to focus on me
I think the issue is people look at
things outside of Islam as freedom and
diverse and individualistic but the
issue is the status quo has already been
set so even outside of Islam there's
still things that they want you to feel
think and operate with
so yes there's it's like a facade of
like choice and all that but there
really isn't bro because we we have this
illusion of choice but when you look at
society and other ways of life aside
from Islam it almost predictates how you
should think and if you hear from that
then you're no longer
good or moral yeah yeah that's a great
point I mean look at Nick Merks uh as
you can you can believe whatever you
want but as soon as you make a general
tweet like leave the kids out of it
you'll lose your entire Call of Duty
collection and sponsorships want to drop
you in it's this whole Feud and all
these people who are against you so you
can't like it's like you can believe
what you want but you're going to be
punished if you believe this this and
that it's so UK you don't have the
choice and on top of that
freedom should people be absolutely free
if people are absolutely free you have
what liberalism was meant to be which is
anarchy you have this Anarchist
liberalism which is everyone's free to
do anything they want no government no
rules to Pure Anarchy and maybe there
are a few people philosophers even who
wanted this initially then you have
um liberalism that brings police and
governments and and and judges and
authorities over the people that the
people allow for the sake of you know
unity and and put some kind of
protection
but it doesn't protect you from yourself
government's not going to stop you in
some countries from offering yourself
they're going to help you do that if
that's what you want if that's what you
desire it's not going to stop you from
drinking or smoking or doing any of
these things that harm your body they're
going to tell you oh it's bad but
they're going to let you do it
and at the end of the day this Society
is breaking people so why would it be
good if you could choose to hurt
yourself that's stupid
it's all right with that because it
brings in money
exactly exactly that's another aspect
capitalism
um it's a huge aspect of it
um liberalism is free dumb of the
individual capitalism is freedom in the
markets free markets privatized markets
which means you can have one person who
is so rich that he owns all the markets
and got into everything before anyone
else did and privatized it basically
only for himself and everyone else is
like
the bottom and here's the top pure
capitalism is that by the way yeah
selling Islam is not profitable bro
yeah actually it is Allah will you know
to the oligarchs to the elites it's not
yeah but you know Spann a lot this is
what I actually I think this really ties
into the next topic which is Andrew Tate
so inshallah soon by the way guys we're
going to move into a uh calling uh gold
to the three Muslims Discord in the
description go to the call-in show uh
and then in the waiting room
specifically and we'll bring you guys up
so we could talk about
um the entertain situation but
subhanallah
when it comes to Islam and what it came
to do every single Prophet came to their
people if you look at the the Surah
titled The Poets
uh in the Quran towards the end you see
Allah mentions all these different
prophets he went to the people and said
oh people you know basically worship
only Allah only worship Allah and obey
me the prophet is saying obey me why
because we need to reform society and
structure in a way that God wants
this is what Islam came to do submission
the whole state submits to Allah the
leader of the state submits to Allah
every citizen submits to Allah
and lives in the way that he wants human
beings to live this is what Islam came
to do now when Andrew Tate mentions
something I guess along those lines
people really went against him for some
reason there are a few things to tell in
the podcast I think were definitely
wrong and they need to be kind of talked
about from his own perspective but this
was definitely not one of them
so he mentioned that Islam is is is
practical
and people stand up for the religion
Islam is something basically that that
is practical for people in life and
that's something that he likes
and people are like that's not all Islam
is it's not just practical it says yeah
it's not just practical
but in our implementation of it it is
fully practical
so why would it be wrong from Dimension
one of the the by the way Islam is
basically the only reason that has this
Judaism has it but then they lack the
spiritual
and they have too much of it if anything
that's why Jesus came to make some of
their laws easier for them and as
instructed by Allah Islam came to be
practical Islam came to say you need to
clean yourself like this people make fun
of Islam for this so it tells you how to
clean yourself
you wish you knew how to clean yourself
people don't use water when they after
they use the bathroom man you know how
disgusting that is stop her a lot people
need to be taught these things it sucks
yeah but people need to be taught people
need to be taught how to engage in
business transactions so they don't
wrong each other people need to be
taught that people need a practical way
of life that's why Islam came to stop
the high Elites from taking advantage of
the the lower weaker people to equalize
people as much as possible so tell
everyone that they're all potentially
could be loved by God no matter their
race no matter their upbringing no
matter their economic status
but by virtue of good deed and good
religion
this is what I was saying what I was
saying before that everything was
programmed into us and that these
these things or these people that are in
control
they have their own agenda they have
what they are trying to
heard
the human sheep
so to speak right we're being hurted and
we don't even realize that we're being
hurted
and for someone who thinks that Islam is
too strict and too rigid
I mean just think about it when you
follow Islam it allows you
to purify yourself
it allows you to get in the best state
mentally
physically emotionally spiritually
and is not asking for any money is not
asking you to do anything that's harming
any other person in this world
so you tell me
you tell me is it really that strict or
is it actually the thing that's meant
for us if it's doing such good for us
yeah that's a great point and just to
quickly piggyback off that imagine a
society where it's complete Anarchy
anyone could do literally anything that
they want or anything that they're
physically capable of doing our society
right now
would be seen as strict
because in their society they can do
literally anything so since our society
allows us to do basically anything to
ourselves
well now Islam which is normal by the
way it's the enormousy now that seems to
be strict
I want to go back to Anarchy for a
second
because when you look at liberalism
and their way of life
it's on Britannica you can look it up
I think it was
I think Thomas Paine I don't remember
exactly who the name what the name was
but he's a philosopher
and he basically argued that governments
are against liberalism
judges are against liberalism police are
against liberalism
the reason we have to have them is to
ensure some kind of protection of
the freedoms of the individual
so it's basically seen as what they
would call a necessary evil
even in their fundamental basis
which the human being is Born Free
to do basically whatever they want
even in that basic General fundamental
belief they have to turn their backs on
that and introduce some kind of Dogma
some kind of strictness some kind of
authority over the people because they
know how stupid it is how silly it is
the founding fathers of liberalism
now all these years later were living in
it we're in the Melting Pot of it or in
the middle of the whole conundrum
and until you look back and see how this
started and the trajectory is to
everyone on and where we are in that
trajectory and where we're heading
you're not going to understand anything
you know it's it's like the analogy
animal always gives if you're looking at
a picture like this you're going to see
one pixel you're not gonna see the full
picture until you back up or until you
back up sorry back to too far away from
my mic but you know you don't see the
whole picture until you back up so once
you back up see where did we start how
do we get here where are we going you
can put two and two together and say
okay well that's pretty messed up the
whole reason we got here is because
Christianity and the church oppressed
people and they got so mad about it
they're like I want to be as free as
possible No One's Gonna Hold Me Down
that's literally what started this whole
chain of events and why people see
religion as evil
just think about that for a second
that's the reason yeah that's the reason
historically look into it
this makes me think of before I became
Muslim I used to look at religion as a
very bad thing
but the more that I started going into
spirituality and I speak spirituality
because I didn't I didn't want to refer
to spirituality as religion I saw the
things as two separate things and I used
to do the whole meditation thing and
like the more I did this the more I
purified myself
I feel better
I felt more in tune I felt like I was
living the way that I was supposed to be
living
and it started to get me closer and
closer to the truth and then it's not
until later on once I accepted Islam
once I became Muslim that I was like
this this whole belief pattern that I
had before was a limiting belief pattern
and looking back it was something that
was instilled into me ever since I was a
little kid I'm gonna keep going back
into that but I'm gonna leave it there
because I'm definitely running in
circles and I have to go pray Maghrib I
love you guys for the sake of Allah
okay I love you for loving us for a sake
inshallah no worries
um you're you're gonna also pray
yeah but I'll leave in a few minutes
because for me Margaret is not as early
as anho because he is down south so I
only have a few minutes left yeah bro
I'm Gonna Let You Go inshallah if you do
have time after Maghrib you can come
back yeah we're gonna do the Colin
challenge yeah I'll jump in with audio
only just because I can't be in this you
don't want to be stressed yeah no no I
can't be can't be in this area is not
gonna work okay got you shut up
so
Allah
all right so I think we're going to
switch over to the um Discord call-in
show um so everyone inshallah get in
there make sure you guys are ready to
hop in
and I'm gonna make sure that we are all
set on our end
it's okay
oh no I could lay her up bro it's just
it's been so cold I feel you man I feel
you I love you subtle bro
thank you I wish I could say they're my
plans but they're not
um but back to the uh the topic of
Andrew Tay so recently he did a live
stream or Another live stream part of me
a podcast which was like four hours long
I think part two was coming out with
Patrick David and the valutainment team
and obviously with a podcast that long
there's going to be a lot that's
discussed a lot that said and there are
a few Muslims who took some clips of
what he said put on Twitter and
basically expressed oh I'm so
disappointed in Andrew how could he say
this this stuff is unislamic this stuff
is wrong and
I think actually what they're posting
about Andrew is wrong in in many ways
and that's what I want to talk about
inshallah so if you believe if you guys
are like Mad at Andrew or whatever and
you want to discuss that please join the
Discord and discuss if you think that
Andrew is Justified
um or or you know there's a
justification for the brother uh also
jump on inshallah we can discuss that
we're gonna migrate over there
um before we start the discussion but
that's what it's about
if I do want to jump on underscore with
me yeah bro I'm gonna I'm gonna attempt
it inshallah it works inshallah
sounds good all right
so I'm gonna set it up real quick do I
do I mute this website right now I would
say just close it yeah I would just
honestly just leave and then join
Discord and I'll share the screen there
all right can you guys see my screen can
you guys still hear me by the way
just want to confirm
how are you guys hamdullah we're doing
good we're finally all back together
um for a stream which feels very very
good
oh great I don't know if that's
sarcastic or not but I'm gonna take it
can you hear me how's the audio sounds
good
um can you guys hear fayad and me
do we turn on video or no
um yeah I should have I should have done
that let me do that now
boom all right
we miss you all
may Allah bless you okay so it looks
like everyone can hear us which is good
um yes
you are brainwashed into Arab culture or
not Islam
okay can you justify that can you
show why you think that instead of just
making a claim
well I mean really can you guys do a
podcast with us I think that'd be pretty
sick he's an amazing
um linguist of of um the Arabic language
or if he's not linguish he's well up
there in his studies on it so I think
that would be amazing
all right so guys if you're down please
inshallah join the Discord live chat we
can't hear the guess so you guys cannot
hear fired right now
no no way no my volume's all the way up
so
someone said bro Rami isn't in Arab yeah
I am alhamdulillah
all right guys Chad can you hear me I
hear fired I can hear it okay so it's
just not one person someone said Rami is
Bengali romi's not a big deal but your
camera is like flipped and odd so this
is actually the right way my camera is
supposed to be the last way it was is
the wrong way because the what we're
using doesn't let you mirror your camera
and OBS is not working I'm gonna mute
myself because of the train so I'll let
you take over inshaallah
or not it's okay
when are you guys bringing back Ibrahim
X formerly known as Lord Baron shallow
soon
I think that'd be good
um tamim are you with us my man
no he's not in the church okay we have
someone in the bedroom I'm gonna bring
them on inshallah
U alaikum
assalamu
how you doing bro
so what brings you here
I really just got the notification for
YouTube I was just showing the waiting
area
um
no worries inshallah so do you know what
we're going to discuss
oh yeah about uh just pearly things in
her uh comments about uh
Islam and Andrews hit
um actually we're going to discuss
Andrew Tate okay yes Central yeah so did
you see the clips do you know what we're
talking about when we say that there's a
few you know clips that people didn't
like
uh yeah
[Music]
um
I saw the interview you know I still
have some I guess
thoughts about it you know that are
probably not not as popular as I'd like
to think just because I
I'm not entirely sure that Andrew Tate
went to jail I guess I'll just put it
like that well okay well what do you
mean by that
so
how can you get you know how he wasn't
able to eat food and he was fasting and
all these things and he was tweeting out
you know comments and he was also active
in Hustler's University while he was in
uh prison right well he came out gaining
uh muscle mass you know and he was
active in Hustler's University at the
time so it just doesn't really add up to
me and I feel like uh you know when he
was released it all adds up
um with the day that the Matrix the
movie which he so avidly talks about was
released so it's like all these sort of
things uh don't really align with his
whole uh idea that he went to jail for
the time that he did so it just it
brings up some questions I see him just
say that so I think it's a little too
speculative and I don't think it like I
don't think it makes sense because there
are there's documentation by the
Romanian government by the courts by the
police talking about how they arrested
him how they put him in jail they were
Court hearings and then official
documents released about those Court
hearings about how they're extending it
and all all that stuff so I I think that
maybe if it was a one-sided thing that
he was the only one claiming he was in
jail maybe but there is so much evidence
to show that he actually was and at the
same time yeah he was tweeting from
Twitter but he wasn't it wasn't him
doing that he would um from what I heard
he would tell people who he saw and then
they would kind of tweet on his behalf I
don't think he actually had a phone uh
and about the fasting thing he um
he said that he would get the food
during the day and then wait till the
sun goes down uh and then eat it to the
best of his understanding of when the
sun went down I don't know if he had
windows and stuff and then he would
um about the lean muscle mass thing uh I
don't know to be honest uh he looked
pretty similar
um to me but I have no idea
yeah
so I mean do you see how it's just a bit
speculative to say that he was never
arrested
yeah it is but I mean you can I I don't
know I always question things to the
furthest extent and then bring myself
back and then try to find a medium yeah
because you know truth is it's a hard
thing a hard thing to find outside of
Islam yeah so yeah that's fair that's
fair so all right anything else I'm
gonna bring someone else uh into the
room as well so we can all all four of
us can chat
[Music]
grumpy monkeys
give me a second I'm just meeting you
guys on YouTube explain yourself
you don't remember me
I remember I remember you
no I I
can't hear me sir
I can hear him
no I can't hear him bro oh okay I
remember last time I was with you guys
when you were talking about the um
on the stream and see if anyone else can
hear him
I heard myself twice I had to mute
YouTube so I don't
like the audio again damn bro you know
what's crazy on YouTube I can hear it
but on my my thing I can't can you check
maybe he's muted on your maybe last time
you muted him and it carried to this
time
yeah
there we go
one two one two testing testing testing
testing I got you yeah there you go
how are your brothers
so what did you what did you do last
time for me to meet you I don't remember
I don't remember either I don't know I
don't think there was a reason for you
immediately it's from the store fresh
bro it's probably your name
uh
yeah it's a cool name thank you thank
you very much
so what's the issue I mean I feel like
Andrew Tate keeps on getting Flack for
saying water's wet I don't know why
people keep getting upset with him did
you did you see some of the clips that
people were tweeting I I saw the whole
interview
I saw I saw the whole interview but I
don't know why people were getting mad
or like people were a bit triggered I
think one of the main videos that was
like circulane was the fact that like
when he was talking about God and then
he was talking about God as a concept
and people were like
um
people are a bit upset that you know
he's not describing God as like you know
traditional Summit he's just trying to
explain to God by trying to explain God
as if he was explaining it to an atheist
and not sort of using the like uh you
know the theological Muslim Paradigm I
think those were one of the like the
comments or Clips yeah
um by the way I feel like they took this
clip out of context because he said an
atheist should at least appreciate the
concept of God because someone's God
saved you I think something like that
right yeah so it's not like he's saying
what he believes he's saying why an
atheist should uh believe in the concept
of Allah you know or God
yeah yeah
so I think
yeah and see that's the thing when you
listen to these clips you have to be
able to decipher the different ways in
which this this saying could be
understood there are a few instances of
this where he would say something and
people interpret it in the worst way
possible when there is a decent way to
understand it I don't think it's wrong
for him to explain that the way that he
did you know there are people who use
philosophical arguments to prove God
exists and I've done it before as well
and you get to the point where there's
an uncreated necessary being who doesn't
depend on anything and that is the start
of the chain of everything that exists
that's not all God is in Islam that's
not all God is God is also the most
merciful he has 99 Names attributes why
are you limiting God to these four
things we're not limiting God we're just
or you know being able to discuss with
people who are not willing to just
accept the idea of a God for whatever
reason even though it's illogical we're
justifying that belief to them logically
and he's doing the same thing he's
saying that conceptually
um that God saved you now obviously
whether it's compelling or not is a
different discussion but whether it's
it's it's okay or not this is not
something that we need to be attacking
New Rivers which by the way he's still
in the river he's in jail for three
months it's not like he had the freedom
to be a new Reaver for very long so it's
just something I wanted to touch on as
well is that yeah yeah like I feel like
it's pathetic for us not for us but I
think it's very pathetic for like people
to like start attacking him for like the
minute intricacies of like Al Qaeda and
fake and like what he understands I
think Andrew Taylor is a new Muslim I
think he has a pretty uh like he has a
pretty solid grasp from a federal
perspective about like what the religion
is really about yeah and people are are
focusing on these mind like minute
issues when they're not really focusing
on like the main topic that he was like
talking about which is like self-respect
improve yourself I got in jail because I
was trying to purport a
um a truth that like you know men
shouldn't be weak men should be this man
should be that and why that's so but the
way that is dangerous for people who are
like in control and I think that was
like that was his main core message and
also something that people kind of like
flew over is that pbd threw up like not
throughout but in in that certain part
of the interview he was trying to pull
him back to Christianity if anybody
noticed it was like you started like he
was defending Christianity was like you
know but in Christianity so and so he's
like yeah but in Islam it's a religion
everybody respects and then I remember
in the podcast pbd was like and it's
feared and and he'd say like it's feared
because they're like you know
implications like all the terrorists
it's feared and Andrew's like yeah it's
feared but nobody anybody you respect
you have to fear
so it's like you know I think he was he
was trying to poke and prod at that
angle or it's like oh your religion is
fear you know what I mean and then
between brackets terrorism but like
I I think I think Andrew really held up
he was solid like the answer is he
the way he reciprocated that question
was like well nothing you respect
everything you respect you fear yeah I
mean you could be nice to somebody but
you don't you don't if you don't fear
him you don't respect him yeah right and
I think that's something I think that's
something that you touched upon and I
think it's very important is that as
Muslims today
you should be in some capacity quote
unquote dangerous in whatever field you
are meaning that you should be competent
enough
in order to protect yourself from any
sort of
anything that life might throw at you
you know and then we have the same The
Profit uh I don't know if it's a prophet
if it's in the Quran
yeah that's a narration yeah yeah a
Muslim who is strong is better than a
Muslim who is weak and strength can be
can manifest in many forms you can
gather stronger knowledge strong in
physique strong in in
um in your speech yeah right so I think
yeah I think overall the the
argumentation over the things that he
got wrong about Islam are the things
that he you know some of his mishaps I
think that's a that's an auxiliary topic
and I think the main focus should be
like what was the actual message and
what was pbd and the other guy trying to
poke in prod to get out of it yeah you
know what I'm saying that's a great
Point that's a very good point uh
Patrick David is a person who's been on
the record to say some very weird things
islamically and Muslims have commented
on it before he quoted Bill Maher for
some reason like not all teas are Muslim
but all Muslims oh sorry not all Muslims
are Muslim it's like yeah yeah why are
you quoting Bill Maher he's a talk show
host bro like he's not a sociologist
he's not a you know uh T defense agent
like
well it shows pbd's bias PPT has a has a
bias towards Christianity and I mean
like he is Christian so it's it's given
so like whenever he says something like
that I I take it with a grain of salt
and I'd be like yeah of course you're
gonna think that way you know yeah
absolutely but in general I think he he
makes good argument points there are
things that he says that is you know
they make sense again he's one of the
people who are I like to say the clan of
the people who say water is wet you know
they're it's it's funny how you can get
popular on the internet these days for
saying the most obvious things
if you say that one statement you will
be loved and hated by money literally
it's completely split down the middle
it's crazy but I do want to cycle out
the gas inshallah we have four people in
the waiting room I don't want to get
something longer than others so uh
grumpy thank you Brothers for having me
again and Fayed please don't mute me
okay
I'll keep that in mind
all right
um guys can you make Dua for me I have a
final exam today
you you definitely look like a student
bro yeah sadly uh it's like my last exam
in my whole school
you know what's the class
uh chemistry so that's it I hate it gen
cam or what
what are you talking about General
chemistry or is it like something
specific organic you know like it's like
um it's kind of yes you know yeah yeah
it's like yeah what are you guys
learning
uh I don't know the names in English
actually
it's in Arabic I don't know the name of
uh I think it's yeah
let me make it easy for you bro
take care inshallah I mean there was
this there was this point that the other
brother made that what's respect without
fear yeah and when I think of that I'm
like it's not the fact that we have to
be dangerous or violent or anything like
that but we have to be capable of danger
because think about it Society relies on
Cops and law enforcement to be capable
of violence to the bad guy right so this
whole myth of don't be violent don't be
dangerous doesn't really work and if
someone's not capable of harming you how
do you really trust them bro you don't
because you don't know with that danger
or violent capability if they would
actually fold or they would be good men
so I think that a controlled dangerous
Violent Men is way more virtuous in the
eyes of Allah and in the eyes of society
than somebody that simply
harmless Yeah by no choice yeah 100 the
process tell him he said the strong
believer is better and more loved by
Allah than the weak believer but there's
some kind of goodness in everyone so
it's very clear that being strong is
better and makes him more Love by Allah
um but I before I introduce or bring on
the the talk show guest I do want to
mention this uh Super Chat please go
over the clip of Andrew saying something
like maybe in Islamic scholar would
disagree with me but I have no problem
with the gay men he kind of paraphrased
um brother do you want to comment on
that
yes I do all right
so what I want to say is I've seen the
interview and only the religion part to
be honest and the thing that I don't
agree with him is like he did a
fantastic job of course for someone
who's who's only you know has been only
months
being a Muslim and the only thing I
didn't agree with is when he said you
can find God through you know many other
religions you know when Patrick Davis
said like I'm a Christian and he was he
was explaining Christianity to him and
then he said it's okay I believe that
you know you can find or you can come to
God in different ways and I don't think
if that's islamically correct
so well first I wanted to actually
discuss that that first comment that was
made but inshallah we can go back to
after so in regards to this it depends
on what he means this statement there
are many paths to God is not necessarily
wrong in all ways of cancer if you say
many religions to God
that would be wrong but he said in many
ways what is what is a way you know like
for example if he's talked about getting
to God you could be talking about
attaining his pleasure you know pleasing
God working in the way uh the Allah
wants you to work there are many ways
you could do that you know doing extra
Salah giving extra zakat
um you know giving dawah
these are things fasting
but I mean by other religions
yeah that would be wrong you know what I
mean yeah so we're talking about what he
said we're talking about what he said
and if what he said was wrong what he
said could be interpreted if he meant
different religions that's absolutely
wrong Allah he says the Deen in sight of
Allah is Islam in no other way he says
no other Dean will be accepted other
than Islam absolutely yeah no other way
would accept it yeah that's absolutely
true now do we expect Andrew to know
that Dean means a way of life or a full
system and not necessarily so him using
the word way could again it could mean
many different things what like a way to
God it could be a way of pleasing God
you know um or it could be that the end
goal is Islam but the way you get to
Islam is different for people some
people start off as atheists and they
say you know a Godless life is a useless
life and then they find Islam some they
like on Hill Qatar as a Christian and
all the spirituality and go to different
things there are many ways you can get
to Islam and you could say getting to
God is getting tests now like there are
ways you can understand what he said
without it actually being wrong and we
don't know what he fully meant when he
said that which is why it's wrong to
just jump on what he said and and say
okay this is what he meant and he's
wrong you know I'm not saying you're
doing that I went on my homepage today
bro and I saw multiple videos from
YouTubers Muslim YouTubers too I'm not
gonna name any names but they were they
found a problematic that Tate said
the whole thing about even the idea of
God is powerful now we as Muslims
clearly we don't believe Allah to just
be an idea to just be theoretical but I
think they they misconstrued his
intention and what he was trying to say
that even the idea of God like those
people that don't really believe in God
did but they want to believe in the idea
of God how it still creates more
virtuous societies yeah because they
associate the idea of God with morality
and Justice and it still creates better
people that's what he's saying he's
saying that the influence of even the
idea of God of God as an idea is
powerful he's not saying God is limited
to just an idea
it's like it's like a message to
atheists like if you don't believe in
God just keep it to yourself don't try
to make other people disbelieving God
you know because God is a it's a good
chance it's a good thing to have God in
our lives like basically that's what
he's saying and yes I agree with that I
mean when he said like we should always
assume the best of intentions and always
make you know
the the best of
I don't know how to explain this but
assuming the best for a brother you know
and yeah that was my comment and thank
you guys for bringing me on photography
of course
he was saying that if you see alcohol
spilling from your brother's beard
assume that it was spilled on him right
we should always assume good of people
unless they give us reasons to believe
otherwise
Joseph Norton bro is that an alias
uh yo brother you got our our stream
playing in the background I can hear
that call
okay let me let me remove is my uh is my
audio Yeah your audio is on and we can
hear your stream in the background
wow
pretty good I've watched you guys for a
long time so it's nice to actually talk
to you guys the pleasure is ours thank
you so much bless you so
first I want to ask do you want to do
you want to address this comment firstly
did you watch the interview or the clips
yeah I did watch it I watched it as it
was premiering amazing all right only
thing I would say is like people
shouldn't be obviously trying to like
kick him out of Islam or anything but I
don't think we should promote the
interview as like a home run or anything
either so yeah
um that'd really be my only issue but
yeah you know I think the promotion of
you know sex before marriage even though
is kind of like they kind of almost like
pushed him into doing it
um to say that but that probably wasn't
a good look either but yeah you know
he's new he's learning
yeah yeah yeah no you're right that was
the one clip that the thing I mentioned
before that was the one clip that was I
think absolutely wrong in no way in
which it could be understood to be okay
um I don't want to repeat exactly what
he said but
um I'll talk about what Islam says very
very clearly Allah says in the Quran do
not go anywhere near is basically
anytime type of sex outside of marriage
to make it you know simple definition
don't go anywhere near Zena so any idea
of oh I need to get to know her by
Sleeping with her or dating her or
whatever is completely unislamic
completely unislamic and and contrary to
how the prophet sallam and the sahaba
and the tabian tabatarain and the
generations after did it completely
contrary to what stem teaches us to do
and uh there's a punishment for that in
Islam if you're caught doing that you
will be no I'm going bro yeah if you're
caught doing that in Islam you will be
at the very least lashed uh publicly and
if you're married then you'll actually
be given a capital punishment and will
no longer be living
yeah
I actually just yeah yeah
um I actually just had a thought
um there's a lot of a lot of Tate's
brand is kind of promoting a lifestyle
so just kind of like a potential
conflict is that he's gonna that's
something he's gonna have to kind of
address is just
you know bouncing his Islam as he's
learning with um
you know the lifestyle he's promoting
and part of his brand that he's you know
he's actually selling product too so
um I just something I haven't heard a
lot of people talk about so yeah that's
a fair point that's a fair point I think
the reason some people don't want to
bring that up is because I think it
introduces enough skepticism
um we shouldn't be uh kind of indulging
in when it comes to Muslim when it comes
to anonymously you know it's not really
a big deal when it comes to a Muslim
there are very specific rights of you
know not backbiting Islam during that
stuff so even the even putting some
ideas in people's heads like if if
someone were to put the idea into
someone's head that a person like might
have committed zinna that could be
islamically just as bad as a slander and
they could be punished for slender
islamically so it's like we have to be
careful with those things which is why I
think some people didn't mention it but
um there is this comment
uh since you watch the whole thing I
want to ask you about it
um Super Chat says please go over the
clip of Andrew saying something like
maybe an assignment caller will disagree
with this but I have no problem with the
gay man
um that's paraphrase it's not word for
word but I'm sure you remember that part
yeah
um you know and I'll be like because I'm
I'm new to Islam you know I've I've
probably been I've been Muslim almost
two years in August will be two years
um and I use space I used to be you know
that was probably one of the last things
I kind of I used to be very liberal as
far as like you know as long as you know
it doesn't bother me
um like the homosexuality stuff let them
do what they want and I'm not saying I'm
too far away from that anymore but just
the way we see things going in school
nowadays
um with what they're like trying to
force down kids the throats
um with the LGBT stuff I've just kind of
really changed my view on that whole
issue so I don't know what the right
Islamic answer is what he should have
said there but um
I'm kind of still rounding out where I
should be I mean I know it's wrong
islamically but I don't know if like
should we not associate with someone in
a friendly manner see that's the thing
and I think Ellie down made a video and
he made a very similar point I think
it's a very good point
um it depends on what you mean by I
don't have a problem and um you know
friends with if you mean friends like
your best friends with them over Muslims
and you would take them over Muslims
which I think clear is not not what he
meant then that would be an issue but
being friendly with or being nice with
you know you can go to my Instagram up
to this day I had a very nice public
discussion with a gay guy who was
attacking Islam at the time and it was
it was a very positive experience he
took down his videos and changed the
ways and that stuff and you know what's
wrong with that in terms of what people
do privately in the bedroom
no one take my word for this but as far
as I know
islamically as human beings we shouldn't
be spying on people or really caring
what they're doing in their bedroom if
they get caught by four male Witnesses
or there's like video evidence something
like that punishment will be given 100
but we're not even allowed to spy on
people so why should we really care
what's going on in in their bedroom so
even islamically it's like we shouldn't
really care either we should care in the
sense that it's Haram and it's a sin and
of course if we can we will tell someone
don't do as Haram we'll educate people
it's Haram you know forever
but
you know saying that I don't have a
problem with it doesn't necessarily mean
that oh it's not Haram all of a sudden
you know so and the West bro the West
also conveniently has forgotten that if
a man and a woman were to sleep with
each other in public too
they'd have a consequence just like a
man and a man in public initial yeah
exactly 100 so
um that's a great Point uh another same
same person sending leadership chat I
make about the same comment I made this
point because I feel like generally sees
Islam as a tool for Fighting Evil he
does not seem to understand it deeply
and submit to the will of Allah God and
maybe such a sure you can help him comes
from Allah
chooses the guide or leave astray anyone
then they would be guided up to straight
if he Wills you know no person can
really guide anyone else
um uh as you said may Allah guide him
but
let's not speculate about the brother
all right let's not say he is or he
isn't whatever he's our brother in Islam
we love him for the sake of Allah we're
going to support him uh no matter what
uh in support by the way
um the prophet sallam spoke about
oppression he said help the one who's
being oppressed and the oppressor all
right and the Saba were like okay we
understand helping someone who's
oppressed how do you help an oppressor
and the prophet saws said to you help
them by stopping them stopping them from
oppressing others so I think a similar
concept would apply here we help him by
stopping him or educating him on
anything that he's saying that is wrong
islamically speaking most of the things
he said in those clips are posted on
Twitter were not necessarily wrong
except for the sleeping around one that
was the only thing that there's based no
justification for a few more Super chats
and I want to get back to the discussion
and um actually brother uh Joseph is
there anything else you want to say
before I bring the next guest on
uh
do do I have to hop off here uh in a
moment yeah just because I forgot I was
gonna say the only thing I haven't heard
brought up and I do think this was a
genuine you know mistake on his part is
that we he basically said that we're not
even supposed to try and convert people
who are Christian or Jewish or something
like that we we shouldn't force them
obviously but like his actual words were
I don't even think we're supposed to try
and convert you know Christians or Jews
um so this I think like Dao is something
that's like either explicitly said or
implied that it's like an incumbent upon
all of us it's an obligation bro
nonetheless you're right absolutely yeah
yeah
I'm confident about him saying that but
um it was probably just a mistake and
you know I appreciate you guys bringing
me in and you know salaam alaikum
it's a pleasure having you on take care
love bless brother Joseph for speaking
the hook and saying it as it is bro I
mean and may Allah allow people to also
have a little bit of empathy and
sympathy for Andrew Tate because he has
a new rebirth the only difference
between him and the scholars those that
get it right is we're seeing all of his
mistakes bro he's in the public figure
a public eye as a public figure
everyone's seeing all the mistakes he
makes compared to other people behind
closed doors so we shouldn't be too
overbearing because there's a lot of
good that he does and inshallah when we
get the chance to talk to him
or next time we talk to Jewel we can
definitely discuss that shallow no
worries um another Super Chat Brother
Chan says may Allah bless you guys and
your efforts when you're coming back
down to the UAE we need satorial number
two inshallah inshallah soon hopefully
it'll be in the work soon that's uh
that's the plan sure so unfortunately
bro my laptop is about to pass oh right
I don't want to get the stream
demonetized real quick so I will have to
hop off and Primo group inshallah it's
been a pleasure brother boys
I guess uh it's just going to be me and
I'll bring in a few people so we're
gonna have more of a discussion um
before I end off the Stream
it's a lot more like
how are you doing man
um I'm good how are you alhamdulillah
I'm doing good
so what did you want to discuss
um
I was just uh I wanted your guys I mean
I want your opinion on
how would you okay so for context I am a
student college student yeah and you
know how those campuses can be
um so like how do you
sort of navigate through
this college like campus I mean I've
been doing it for two years but like I
just kind of realized that like there's
no point in trying to sort of deal with
it because that just it ends up becoming
a stress up on you
um and then it's kind of
for some people they can do it but like
I used to what I used to do is just stay
by myself in my room all the time and
barely go out which is also something
that like I don't really want to do so
how would you at least socially
recommend going through just College
because the Muslim Students Association
they don't do much and most of the
people you'll talk to get into some sort
of intoxicants
so which issue is is specifically is it
is it a bad influence from other guys or
is it the fact that there are women to
like what what is particular
I would say yeah bad influence from
other
people yeah General that one's simple
you just have to surround yourself with
good Muslims and I'm sure there are even
if it's just one or two I'm sure there
are good Muslims on campus and if you're
a good Muslim inshallah you should bond
with them no problem and just stick with
them don't sit around with other people
don't care what other people are doing
don't get friendly with anyone who you
know you suspect is being weird doing
drugs alcohol going to be about
influence and just only be around for
people this is the advice of the process
the sahaba and there are many Hadith
justify being in good company as opposed
to Bad Company or even being alone as
opposed to being in Bad Company
foreign
if you can't find anyone on campus
um as a last resort I would say you know
stick to like the three Muslims group
chat and Discord find like an online uh
group of Muslim brothers that you can
talk to so at the very least at the end
of the day when you come back home you
have that influence instead of a
negative one you know
exactly
and let's get back to uh the actual
topic at hand so I want to welcome also
Hawk and Muslim Tom Cruise guys how you
doing
man it's quite the name of some Tom
Cruise
hey by the way Rami you commented on my
channel man thanks for that man all
right comment down on your Channel
yeah yeah you said great work man I
really appreciate it man Hey listen I
just want to say yeah like uh actually
the funny thing is you know I know the
topic is about annotate and the podcast
yeah I truly get that yeah so sometimes
what happens is you know when you're
debating atheists or people who follow
liberalism basically they believe in the
harm principle right so when you ask
them about objective morality and
subjective morality when you ask them
this question about the harm principle
so when the harm principle is removed so
when you ask them a question like this
yeah for example and they might respond
respond respond to this yeah like the
question is the question goes like this
yeah but um if a brother and sister
basically have intercourse you want to
have intercourse with each other and
with economy so basically they are
eliminating or let's say the guy goes
and gets them they said to me so they're
limiting eliminating all the chances of
them producing a child with genetic
issues right so they're removing the
harm principle so and then an atheist
might say from his atheistic perspective
he might say oh yeah the harm is removed
so now so now it can be known right yeah
so then his response can be sometimes
you know it wasn't Adam and Eve wasn't
Adam and Eve like they weren't their
children's their committed or something
like that sometimes this response could
be like that yeah so what would you what
would your response be to there so my
response would be that firstly where do
you get morality from if you get your
morality from God then whatever God
dictates
um is is moral right because God will
tell us what is good and what is bad
what is moral what is immoral and he
will give us laws to live by the law is
the Adam and Eve alaikum salaam had when
Allah created them were specific to them
because they were the first human beings
and Allah ordained Allah for them their
law was
children from the same womb can't uh
can't marry and and and be together but
children from the other womb can this is
something that obviously was overseen by
Allah so there's no issue from him so
there is no harm because Allah was
overseeing it if you look at it from
that perspective there's no harm
principle there's no there's no issue or
anything like that uh and Allah ordained
so objectively in terms of morality
there would be no issue and there would
be no case to make for from an atheist
unless they're trying to say we're
hypocritical but we're not saying it's
um categorically wrong for all times and
places all people no matter what we're
saying that Allah decides and for us now
it's wrong because Allah decreed that is
wrong for us for Adam and Eve he had a
specific law that he decreed for them
and morality a moral standing basically
with that law so it wouldn't be an issue
yeah that's that's actually a pretty
good answer thank you thank you so much
man and the second thing is basically I
know that energy keeps talking about
this yeah four wives and four wives and
this and this pretty
um prevalent in the red pill basically
think that sneak also mentions four
wives here to prove his uh uh basically
proof of four wives yeah so he says the
Islam has it here so I know in a lot of
points you know that supports uh the
undeniable evidences for polygen I'm
actually making a video on this so for
example there's hypergamy that proves
there's there's facilitation so uh those
women who want to be with those top 10
or 20 by 20 of men Islam provides their
facilitation there is also a rise of
single parent households Islam also
provides facilitation to them you know
polygeni also you know uh stops
promiscuity in a society by those top 20
20 of men no sleeping with those moments
providing those women the responsibility
and so on and so forth so would you like
I know a lot of points you know that
supports religion you know but you know
any other like points would you say
about like for example like do you know
anything about like any other point that
support polishing like a woman might say
you know like if man can get four men
you know why can a woman get for uh so
but if a man can get four wives why can
a woman get four four men you know I
know there's also our intuition our
faith that rejects it you know for
there's also social shame in
cross-culturally you know a woman that
sleeps with multiple men is called a you
know what so do you have another point
to support this argument for example the
politician I know a lot of things that
actually support this but do you know
any other things that I might be able to
increase my knowledge in
I think what you have so far is pretty
solid I would just go back to the basics
as well it's very important and people
Overlook it's very important that we get
back to the basics when you say it's
wrong or it's okay or whatever this is
not based on some random principle like
harm or
um you know some social construct it's
based on what Allah the almighty the
all-powerful all-wise all knowledgeable
and the creator of everyone has has
commanded so the Creator Universe
command it this way that morally
justifies it for us he's prohibited for
women it's allowed for men that morally
justifies it you can also look at it
from the perspective of a woman doesn't
have to provide for even herself so a
woman's going to be provided by provided
for by four men that doesn't make sense
rather than a man who can provide for
four women and families and provides for
all four of them as someone who's
supposed to take care of them there's
things like sperm competition
yeah and then there's the issue of she
can only get pregnant so many times and
for nine months and then she's gonna be
out of commission like how like what if
if one man is married to a woman that's
married to like three other guys
I don't think she's gonna have the
capacity to be with all of them as
consistently as as they would need
especially if she's pregnant at the same
time like poor woman and let's say she
can spend it you know let's say she
produces a child and that's that's the
first guy she knows the town of the
second guy so the other guys are going
to say sexually you understand like I
get this point man I get this point
hundred percent so there's a lot of
points I'm going to combine all of those
points together yeah it's going to make
a very solid case thank you so much man
seriously man and by the way the thing
that Andrew trade was talking about like
in terms of God as an idea I know he
portrays it as an idea but we can
basically link into intuition you know
like like there's two ways to thinking
about this Jonathan Hyde also talks
about this right analytical thinking and
intuitive thinking so annotate was
talking about in terms of intuition you
know like people believe it's like
there's this inside of them this they
look at it from an innate perspective by
natural perspective thank you so much
Nami yeah seriously man all right take
care all right
no more off-topic questions we're gonna
end up the discussion with entertain
inshallah So speaking out forever hold
your peace
man make a point myself yeah I was here
yeah go for it I think Andrew Tates
specifically was talking about a time
where he would make arguments against
atheists uh but this was like before he
accepted Islam so he wasn't making the
argument right now as like a God as an
idea he was talking about like years ago
how he would use that idea to talk to
atheists so I think we need to like take
the context into the you know we need to
look at the context like you said watch
the whole video of the interview instead
of watching the clip and you know what I
mean
brother
and I don't want a bad mouth Andrew Tate
or like uh you know talk badly about him
I want him to you know become a better
Muslim and spread better like an image
of Islam
you guys I think one of the people made
a combat Super Chat and talked about
sartorial shooter I know you guys had
him on the show yeah do you think you
can like some somehow contact him to
like maybe connect some people to
entertain inshallah to better educated
more like a help him in these matters
and education of the team
bless uh brother Jewel showed her he's
an amazing brother so shout out to him
he's doing some great things and may
Allah bless him and Aid him in that um
in regards to me reaching out um I don't
think we you know I we're really in a
position to do that I know that Andrew
Tate has received the um this kind of
information and perspective from people
I know he definitely has the resources
um so I don't think kind of involving
myself in that way it would actually be
beneficial I think that we'll we'll give
it time and we'll let the brother you
know have the breathing room that he
needs because he's definitely being
pestered online by people left right and
Center so I don't want to add to that by
making it personal I think that'd be
wrong
I think he made some great points
thank you
I'm gonna take this time to read a super
chat before we get the final
um uh speakers
um Ayub says it was an intense convo I
don't blame Tate for messing up a couple
times and the man has been in jail more
than from in jail more than being a
Muslim in the free worlds found Allah
that's a great point and that's very
true man
and Grant the Muslims a little more
patience and understanding
all right so uh Hawk and Heidi is it
okay if I if I remove you guys or put
you back in the waiting room
oh I was gonna say one last night thank
you no worries have you think go for it
I wouldn't say it's just um as somebody
who has had experience with uh reverts
in the past it's just the best thing you
can do is just have patience have supper
because you know they're new to Islam
and especially Andrew Tate who's
extremely new to Islam so yeah this
thing we can have is Summer and you know
my mom always likes to say this was like
maybe in the eyes of Allah he is maybe
more favored than
yeah you can be you know you never know
it's a great Point that's the beautiful
Point bless you and and your mother as
well I think that's an amazing point
s
all right final two speakers and
slingshot welcome guys
all right so what brings you guys on
what do you want to chat about
no basically
um either of you take the mic go for
inshallah yeah
so basically I just want to point out
like okay so like you know for all the
concerning issues that people were
talking about yeah he said this and he
said that this first of all I wanted to
point out he just converted to Islam and
also the fact that he you know like he
didn't have anybody around him you know
he only had one Quran as we've seen you
know in like you know in jail and he had
no knowledgeable person with him so of
course it makes sense that he may clip
up and make some a few mistakes because
because he doesn't have any knowledge
he's still like as one would say he just
converted to Islam he doesn't know
anything you know so I'm saying like um
like he doesn't have anybody
knowledgeable with him that can correct
him or anything we can only like you
know try to like point out the mistakes
and you know that this is wrong or like
you know or like critique him when we uh
like when we know that he's with
somebody and like you know that he's
actually learning about right now like
he was in jail for like nearly what
seven months and and uh and or like six
months and he converted like you know in
like poor jailba like like he didn't
have anything anybody with him he only
had one Quran and he's studying Islam
all by himself so like you know like
yeah of course it like it makes sense
that he might slip up like anybody like
if you had a friend that like you know
he doesn't know anything we wouldn't say
that somebody even like according to
what uh the Hadith says like somebody or
what it's called to say if somebody if
somebody uh is ignorant on their thing
he's not sinful so if I didn't know that
you know like anything like if I didn't
know like just like somebody who just
who didn't know about Islam in the day
of judgment he's going to be tested but
he won't be punished because he was
ignorant he didn't know so I'm saying
that he was just ignorant and you can't
really you know blame somebody who
didn't know anything who just convert it
to Clem and who didn't have anybody
surrounding him who was knowledgeable
yeah yeah exactly I think that's a great
point and um I think most people on here
have kind of taken the same approach
which is that it's it's too soon to
really condemn
um somebody in his position whether it's
entertain or somebody else you know he's
fairly new to Islam uh and and we need
to be more more diligent and and
understanding
so I think that's a great point
Sorry slingshot it's kind of hard to
hear I think your mic's a little bit low
well let me see if I can I can't make
you louder on my end can you get closer
to the mic Maybe
this is good
sorry what you hear me oh yeah I think
it's good chat can you guys hear him
can you hear me
yeah I can I think it's a good down
yeah you're good
my bad
all right so did you want to add
anything to the topic
uh yes I think yeah he is very little
we've we converted
I think is I think it's fair we've all
give him a chance
because just like me I did join here and
everyone was like kind of at me
am I almost drilling well
if I think I was planking it thinking
guys
I remember you wait
I remember yeah
what what's your name again
it won't kill me everyone call me snail
shot snails I remember you bro what was
your name on YouTube
mm-hmm
type 509
always the same name wow subhanallah
yeah I remember you bro and you're
absolutely right my brother oh firstly
it's great to talk to you again hope
you've been well Insha'Allah secondly
you're absolutely right you know with
new reavers people just accept the
Saddam if Allah himself is giving them
that leeway is understanding towards the
fact that they're not going to know uh
everything even just the basics right in
the beginning then why should we as
humans and not give that same kind of
leeway I think that's an amazing Point
yeah everyone remembers you now in the
in the chat
[Music]
my brother let's let's connect offline
as well shallow please send me a text
and let's let's let's talk let's uh
catch up I want all the updates on how
you've been my man
it's been good I've been
pretty good not gonna lie
um been falling for a bit but
[Music]
give me
no yeah
I I kind of have like an off subject
question
okay no worries inshallah we'll make it
the last question for the stream
yeah it's like it's nothing okay so
basically I hadn't I hadn't it's random
but I had an argument with somebody and
uh like basically were questioning how
tall is salami
okay and then and then uh and then you
know I told him bro I seen in a clip
before like he was like he's like six
six six seven or something and then he
told me no no no arani is like rami's
pretty sure he's like probably like five
eight or something and so I just want to
make this clip like I really want you to
answer this because I want to send him
this clip right now oh yeah okay
yeah it's a funny man you guys both you
guys both chose some extremes one's like
super tall one super short I'm I'm I
believe exactly take your guess
so these are some guesses six one the
same guy guest six one six three six e
don't know what that is uh five eight
six one someone said I can confirm Rami
is seven one uh six one five ten six one
six one okay yeah I'm basically six one
or I'm I'm maybe like a quarter of an
inch shorter than six one
there was a joke there was a joke going
around that was six seven or something
like that I think one of the guys made
that made that joke but yeah I'm six one
Handler
oh wow okay yeah yeah okay
well I was so awesome
[Music]
I appreciate your guess because at least
your guess was flattering his guess was
the demeaning
[Music]
any final words for the for me and for
the Stream
well I'm awake um
my beautiful brother inshallah I will
talk to you soon take care
take care bye
what an amazing brother
may Allah bless them
very proud of him definitely come a long
way if you guys go back and watch the
older streams
you'll see you'll see um him in the
comments we're trying to help him take a
shahada and it's just taking long we
thought he was trolling because he just
didn't join forever but alhamdulillah
may Allah bless him he accepted Islam
later on by himself not even with us and
um I guess the rest is history bless him
brother Romney if you put on some muscle
you look like Hercules inshallah
inshallah that's the goal
that's the goal inshallah I'm looking to
get there
very soon
slingshot welcome back
but I think I'm gonna go ahead and end
the stream Michelle I'll take maybe a
few comments if there's any last Super
chats please send them now so I can
address them before we end
bro you asked this like 27 times
20s like a billion times bro insha Allah
we want to I think that'd be cool or at
least I want to I have to talk to the
brothers about it mashallah we'll see
please stop commenting this
have you have you seen navigating
differences I've heard a lot about it
but I haven't seen it so I can't comment
on it
but I I think I know what it's about
why did
yeah Patrick day I think in Patrick but
David
um give Tay a Bible as a gift I think
it's similar to like when I gave Dr
Dennis McDonald a copy of the Quran it's
not really a bad thing
um in my opinion
what happened to Lucid X3 Muslims it's
gonna happen inshallah it's going to
happen
too many videos on navigating
differences
yeah if you guys want commentary on that
initial you can go over to his channel
and see what he said
um I can't really give uh much feedback
I haven't seen it or write it or
whatever it is
about David gave a Bible and a Quran
okay that's nice that's very nice why
are you guys giving half the story man
give the full story as Muslims we need
full context from
I'm sorry it's okay well I'll bless you
can I talk to you privately uh just DM
me I'll try my best to respond and get a
lot of dance from people so I I'm not
able to get to everyone
sneak on Morocco finding a Muslim life
may Allah bless them uh make him may
Allah make him a good husband and bless
him with a good wife or wives I mean
did you guys talk to Young Don I had a
brief conversation with him I think he's
a he's a he's a good brother
um I'm proud of him
um but I think you also needs space to
continue to learn uh for himself
uh he's always invited to the stream uh
honestly I think as a Christian even as
a Christian I love him I think he's a
great guy and I think he's really really
grown a lot
as as everybody in hamdullah
yes
did clean the garments of the process to
them
um semen and other things
I don't know why you felt like you need
to comment that but it's a Hadith
I think you wish you could get your wife
to do that for you
uh so we're not doing Colin right now
inshallah you can hop on next week
can you comment on the I didn't watch a
full interview I didn't get that far
into it so I I don't remember that part
so I can't comment on it
guys I think it's gone on for too long
I'm going to go ahead and end it may
Allah bless you all immensely
[Laughter]
see you guys on the next one